[Narrator] Now that you survived the bunny uprising,
we're ready to get to the main goal of this class as far as building the search engine.
Our goal is to improve the results by finding the best webpage,
instead of just returning a list of all the webpages that match a query.
As the web has grown, it's become more and more important for search engines to do this ranking well,
that what really distinguished Google from previous search engines
was they had a much smarter way of ranking pages that produced more useful results
where the first 1 or 2 results in response to a search query were often the very thing that the user was searching for.
Now we're ready to start thinking about the problem of how to rank webpages.
Let's start by recapping how our search engine works.
We started by building a crawler, and what the crawler did,
and this was what we did in units 1, 2, and 3;
what the crawler did was follow all the links in the webpages,
following those links, building up an index, and
the end result of the crawler, after units 4 and 5, was we had an index.
By the end of unit 5, it was a hash table where we could look up a key word,
and we would find entry where that key word might appear,
and we would follow that, and we could look through each of those entries
to find the one that matched and that would match the key word we were looking for,
and as its value it would have a list of all the URLs where that key word appears,
and the order of those URLs in that list was determined just by how we added to them to the crawl.
Every time we encountered a new page,
we indexed that page and we added a URL for that key word.
The one that's first in this list is just the one that we happen to find first.
Say it's the C page, the one that's second would be the one that we find next,
and it's this page.
This doesn't tell us anything about which page is best.
The order of the URLs in the list and what we were getting as your output
just depends on the order that things happen to go in the crawl.
When the web was really small, which was quite awhile ago now,
this was sort of okay that there were only a few pages that might match a given key word,
and you could look through them all and decide what one you wanted.
With the web today, this doesn't work at all.
There are thousands of pages that match any interesting key word, maybe millions,
certainly many more than you want to look through by hand.
The most important thing that a good search engine does is figure out how to rank these pages,
so the one that the user gets is to figure out how to rank these pages
so the one that's at the front of the list is the one the user wants.
That's our goal for the rest of this unit to figure out how to rank pages.
Before we do this for web pages, we're going to do something very similar but perhaps easier to relate to.
We're going to talk about how we decide whose popular.